and overall it appears that toine
abundance um Associates uh with health
status in humans and low to in abundance
is associated with poor health in humans
so hello and welcome to the Shiki
science show where in this video I spoke
with f YF assistant professor at the
department of genetics and development
at Colombia University researching
functional connections between human
metabolism and disorders earlier this
year his team published on the role of
touring and how supplementation in a
mouse model improved many markers of
Health here we discuss fj's interest and
research further so hi FJ thank you for
joining me today and welcome to the
Shiki science show thank you very much
for the invitation it is my pleasure to
be on your
show thank you so uh earlier this year
you had a publication uh that caused a
lot of interest um for a lot of people
on the internet about touring um and
touring metabolism and its influence on
Aging phenotypes but before we get there
I'm actually even more interested in
some of your earlier research that you
did before getting to that stage as I
think it will also help us I guess
understand why that uh focus and
interest came to touring um and so
firstly I noticed that one of your
earlier Publications was um about the
Corpus lithium and uh the regulation and
of apoptosis and I was just wondering if
maybe you could elucidate a bit on your
early interest in science and the work
that you're
doing sure so my interest um in doing
research uh goes back um to 19 maybe
late 80s um when I used to go to my uh
father's um workplace he was a finance
person but uh he worked in a Science
Institute which is a central drug
Research Institute in in lakau in India
so whenever my mother um
thought that it was a vacation day and
uh we had nothing to do and she wanted
to get rid of us she just put us on his
uh vehicle and uh put us to his office
so that she has a some free time uh
raising three kids is not a small thing
so um so we just used to run around in
in his office area uh not to so much to
do with the money um but uh because it
was Science Institute we had exposure to
um going to Laboratories um at that
point there were regulations were a bit
less uh so the kids used to we are
running around the nyar olds which are
going around in the labs you know you
can imagine today happening it is going
to be a bit lot of
regulations so um I remember one of my
first interaction was um that somebody
was dissecting a cat uh they were
working on diabetes and my question to
the gentleman who was doing the
dissection of a cat was um what are you
doing he said we are discovering
medicines for
diabetes and that was my first question
I could remember okay now these initial
episodes I think were very uh important
uh because they were those were
formative years and that created an
interest in me in
research and when I finished my Masters
in Biochemistry um I did uh start my PhD
in um Indian inst of Sciences in
Bangalore uh working on how female
reproductive physiology is regulated by
endocrine
systems and uh in particular we were
looking at the effect of ovarian
physiology on the implantation process
in the
fetus and when I started my PhD my PhD
supervisor asked me what do you want to
work on I said I would like to work on
how um menual cyclicity is regulated
during fertile and non-fertile Cycles in
humans and uh how can we help to
understand this process better he said
that is a very poorly understood area um
and I asked him this question uh way
back in
1999 is that why it is a poor
sudaria he said that because if you want
to really relate uh human physiology you
have to use monkeys as a model
system and um well I again asked him why
he said that because no other species on
this planet under goes mensturation uh
like humans do which we think are the
highest evolved species on this planet
except uh humans and higher order
primates
monkeys I was not aware of these things
because you know as a PhD student you
are starting you are looking at
physiology but you are not aware of the
intricacies of different
processes and he said if you want to
really work on this problem you would
have to use monkeys as model
system and one thing I learned from him
uh early on during my career was that if
you want to address a biological
question you have to use the best model
system
available and uh he told me if you
really want to do this um you have to
really be prepared that your experiments
are going to last 3 to four years each
experiment and you have to overlap them
uh so that you can finish your PhD in
time well um for good I took that
challenge and uh we started
understanding how uh ovarian glands are
formed and during the process of the
menual cycle uh and one of the transient
endocrine gland in the body uh is Corpus
litium which actually is formed after
ovulation happens and it produces
progesterone uh to help in the
implantation process it repaires the
uterus for implantation to
happen and Corpus luum failure is one of
the major uh problem for early pregnancy
failures and so during this course of
the initial formative years we use
monkeys as a model
and then we went back to Cows as a model
bid species and rats as a model to try
to see how Evolution has shape this
process and we evolve to a being which
um has this uh unique um menal cyclicity
and that is that is changed during the
fertile
cycles and during the course of these
studies I became interested in female
diseases uh after menopause because
menopause is nothing but failure of the
ovarian
system not a failure of ovian system I
would call it it is basically an
exhaustion of the uh egg deposits in the
ovaries and therefore leading to uh
menopause and this happens around 45 to
50 year old uh in
humans now these um studies led me to
understand female diseases of menopause
such as osteoporosis diabetes and
obesity uh during my postt talk years uh
and I I did not have enough training in
Ma gentics at that point to be able to
mutate genes to be able to do
conditional mutagenesis to address uh
physiological
questions and during my post talk uh I
worked on osteoporosis um obesity and
how appetite is regulated uh in all
these uh energy metab demanding
processes and after I finished my post
talk I um started looking at how
different uh nutrients uh and these
processes are affecting the uh processes
of Aging uh because all these processes
get clustered and they get um together
uh at the end of our lives and we start
experiencing this morbid period uh which
is pretty long for a human being and uh
in order for us to compress this morbid
period at the end of our Lives we need
to understand this aging process better
and that is where we I started my
independent career looking at different
um uh nutrient molecules and different
genetic factors uh which predispose us
to these aging diseases um and that is
what led me to in the initial years led
us to discover the importance of vitamin
B12 an essential nutrient uh coming from
animal based TI only uh in regulating
human physiology and that led us further
to a role of torine in regulating um
various uh physiological problems uh or
various physiological um phenotypes such
as growth uh and uh bone density uh in
early part of our lives and that is
where we started to address this
question of uh The Wider role of toring
across organ systems and we stumbled
upon the effect of toine during the
aging process wow there that's a lot of
experience um and awesome how they all
sort of followed on from each other um
because you mentioned uh the
relationship about vitamin B12 and with
osteoprosis um but generally what is
known about vitamin B12 and how is it
used within
cells so vitamin B12 is very interesting
molecule it is one of the most most
complex vitamin of
all in fact it has a very interesting
story um so uh till about
1910 uh there was a disease known as
pernicious anemia and there was no cure
for
it and then um a scientist created this
animal model whereby he was bleeding
dogs and feeding them different
diets um and trying to identify is there
a dietary component to pernicious emia
and when he blood these dogs and he fed
them animal based products like liver
raw liver and muscle their anemia was
reversed so he noted um that perhaps
there is something coming from the liver
that is a very important molecule or a
factor that is regulating the anemia
process based on these initial findings
without knowing what is present in liver
that is um curing Anem IA in dogs
now two clinicians um decided to feed
humans with raw liver so something like
500 G of Raw Liver uh served to you on a
plate in the morning you can imagine uh
what your response is going to be uh but
people were dying from this disease that
is why it is known as pernicious so they
had no
option very surprising thing that these
clinicians noted one in Canada and one
in the US say that when they fed humans
with raw liver their anemia reversed and
within four to 6 months they started
walking and running
around wow from the phase of immobility
they were able to now walk and run
around I had this wonderful video which
was published in blood journal and I was
trying to look for it for some time but
I have not been able to find but that
shows how a bedridden person with
pernous anemia is start eating raw liver
and then he starts to walk then he
starts to run so this till till that
point till about 1930s we had no idea
what was in the liver that was curing
pernicious
anemia well three people got Nobel Prize
for it for feeding humans raw liver and
curing AIS anemia bipple Mino and Murphy
in
1934 and that is the greatest example of
how important it is to um really
identify cures of a disease without
knowing in fact sometimes um what it is
that you are doing that is curing the
disease well 20 years later uh than
Dorothy Hodgkins in the in United
Kingdom then she actually identified the
structure of vamin V got a Nobel Prize
for it
again um
and it also elucidates that okay we from
the point of a basic scientists
clinicians and then a structural
biologist how we were able to identify a
molecular origin of a
disease uh well and till that point
there was only way we could synthesize
um well there was no way to synthesize
B12 till
1950s um then these um labs in one in
Harwood
um I'm skipping the name uh
aren Mo in
Switzerland and Woodward if I I I I you
can correct me if I may be wrong there
Woodward in horwood they synthesize B12
chemically and it took them around 15
years to do so in fact Woodward's lab
was burned down completely during the
process once wow because it was so
complex a molecule uh they had to
collaborate with the the Swiss Labs
would really see the precursors and then
going back and forth to be able to do so
at the end they were able I think in
sometimes in um late 1960s they were
able to synthesize completely the B12
and after that we have the synthetic B12
available anyway I think it was a bit of
a long route I uh you were not probably
expecting uh me to narrate but this is
how the B12 um came in picture where you
have this disease uh molecule gets
identified and then you have uh being
you have it available to uh people to
cure um pernicious mean anemia and later
part of our Lives we do have this
vitamin B12 deficiency major chunk of us
go through this betal deficiency phase
uh when we are 60 year
olds and this episode um also
illustrates the importance of nutrients
coming from specific dietary
Origins which are important for our
health
and perhaps it is a uh time to to better
understand what nutrient molecules are
actually required for our health we have
barely any idea of what are the
nutrients which are essential or
semiessential for us for a Better Health
yeah no that was firstly a super
interesting story but Al I think you're
completely right I mean as still as even
today when people talk about health no
people tell you take too much vitamins
so not enough one and it's not just
vitamins in general it's different types
of vitamins as you just mentioned and so
both vitamin B12 um is it mainly free
diet that we get it or what to what
extent is our bodies capable of
naturally producing it B2 cannot be
produced by human body uh it is only
the well the the the reason for that is
that only some
bacteria in Animal Kingdom can
synthesize
V12 and these bacteria need to be
present in earlier part of the GI
tract such as in ruminants there is a uh
there's a pouch uh before the
stomach uh which in which can house the
bacteria and bacteria can synthesize it
uh and then when it passes through this
stomach uh and the intestine uh there's
a protein produced only by the stomach
cells know as a gastri intrinsic factor
that binds to B12 and that helps in the
absorption so if B12 is synthesized in a
later part of the GI tract it cannot be
absorbed it can only be absorbed if it
is present before the stomach and that
ruminants can do it uh and when we eat
these muscle products or liver or animal
based diet uh we are able to obtain B12
from these diets and today we can do it
synthetically as
well I see and so is it still unclear as
to once you you got vitamin B12 in the
body what it's interacting with or how
is it actually functioning in the
cell well it has been a while since uh
B12 was discovered and people have
worked on variety of different molecular
processes within the cells um only two
known enzymes
are requiring B2 over cells that one is
munian synthes and other one is
um uh mut which is present in the crap
cycle um and these two enzymes um are
requiring this B12 as a co-actor
modifications of B12 as a co-actor uh
and then Downstream of these processes
you have variety of changes happening in
the cell
which is still at a cellular level at a
metabolic level we do not understand
precisely uh and that is where we
stumbled upon a role of uh toine uh
because we were trying to figure out how
B12 is affecting
the uh growth and Bone metabolism in
animals and when we so we were not
noting there was a decrease osteoblast
function in these vitamin B12 deficient
animals but when we put B12 on top of
these bone cells nothing happened to
them right so we thought okay there must
be some endocrine origin of this uh B12
action in these animals and b12 is as
the pernicious anemia episode tells you
it is predominantly stored in
liver and to an extent in muscle and
recycled in the
body and so we did a metabolomic
analysis in Bol deficient lers um way
back I was in Cambridge that time uh and
we identified that through metabolomic
analysis that Beal deficient libers have
variety of Downstream processes that are
perturbed and um through machine
learning and other methods we could then
narrow it down to uh processes which are
critical for B2 deficiency to
precipitate its um effect on body
systems and we identified that in B12
deficient labors there was a dramatic
reduction on 95 to 98% reduction in
toine levels in these livers wow and if
you supplement B12 deficient livers with
toine you are able to uh help their
organ
functions and that led to the
identification the B12 regulates toine
biosynthesis and through that means it
is able to affect an in endocrine manner
uh a bone deposition and growth
phenotypes in different um cell
types interesting because uh so with
torine I know that we can get it from
diet and I think we'll come on to that
shortly but we in torin's case it can be
synthesized in the liver cells if I'm
correct and so what you're saying is
that there seems to be maybe Upstream a
link between ftim and b12 and regulating
this this generation of toine within
liver cells but uh you mentioned about
the crab cyon obviously and that uh
toine is uh can be synthesized from
cysteine which is an amino acid unlike
toine which is a free amino acid but
then amino acids are sort of can be
generated off from the CB cycle I mean
maybe not sustain my by chemistry
knowledge I should be better than this
but um yeah I would you be able to
elaborate more and or speculate on maybe
how you think these two are related yes
so the amino acid metabolism um or crab
cycle uh as you mentioned uh have
intricate relationship because many of
the amino acids are metabolized uh
through crap
cycle through variety of
intermediates and although crab cycle is
classically known to be associated with
the uh production of energy by producing
these
nadh uh
molecules uh in
mitochondria it also has a very
important role to play in anabolic
reactions so when it comes to energy
prod production is a catabolic reaction
when it comes to different intermediates
being produced by the craft cycle there
are anabolic reactions as
well and cine is one of the known
precursor of torine in the liver
cells um for toine to be biosynthesized
in the cells we do have a limited
capacity to synthesize uh
torine uh and it is a free amino acid as
you mentioned uh because it has a suon
group in place of a carboxy group which
is required to make peptide bonds in in
proteins it remains to the most part as
a free amino
acid and torine um is interesting in
many regards uh because um its known
functions um are related to senin
related to uh cell proliferation and so
on but having said that cine is the
precursor of toine uh there are other
means to synthesize toine as well and
that we are stumbling upon now and what
are the critical requirements for
different molecules I like you mentioned
B12 is an upstream regulator of toine
biosynthesis in liver cells and very
interesting Bol is stored in the liver
toine is um produced in a major way uh
in the
liver
however during the course of our
lifespan there are phases in which we
cannot produce
toine such as in during the uh during
during the perinal period babies cannot
synthesize toine and they're dependent
from mother's milk to obtain that that
toine and that is why many of the
formulas that you see in the market
today are supplemented with
toing right without knowing what it is
doing only thing people have predicted
that it may have some role to play in
the growth um of um um babies and during
the later part of our life we start
developing some ability to a limited
extent to synthesize toine in tissues
like liver uh in pancreas to an extent
in brain to an extent but many tissues
are deficient in toin production and
they're dependent on the dietary intake
in humans I'm talking about Dr intake as
well as limited amount of toine being
synthesized from these different
organs such as for example muscle cannot
synthesize toin at
all and therefore the first symptom that
one sees in toine deficiency it is
actually muscle wasting and uh
neurological
symptoms I see and so um in terms of how
we can get toing that from a dietary we
need this a transporter present as well
right to be able to take that into the
cells as I believe that there's a mouse
model that's been generated to sort of
mimic the absence of the dietary intake
of torine and that was yeah by
inhibiting the transporter but is so
that's the only transporter to get
torine into cells uh it is not but that
is the predominant transporter so SLC
686 is the predominant transporter which
is required on the cells for toine
uptake because when you knock out this
transporter um majority of the tissues
have this toine
deficiency however this is not the only
transporter toine can also be exported
from the cell uh by voltage regulat Anon
Channel it has many other Transporters
which are present on neuronal cells for
example on intestinal epithelium for
example uh for dietary absorption and
there for that is not the only
transporter but that is one of the
dominant transporter required for toine
to be taken into the cells and that is
SLP
686 I see I say when I read your paper
earlier this year um I was trying to
find out more about Tori not just how
it's metabolized but also like what is
actually doing within a cell and it
seems seems to be doing many different
things within a cell as youve mentioned
a few already but from that to like
mitochondrial translation all way like B
acids um and fat multipication I just
want um yeah how much is really known
about what toine is actually doing
within a
cell so there are many processes which
have been associated with toine such as
regul regulation of Osmosis uh because
it a free amino acid uh it has a Charged
amino group as well as sual group uh so
it is functions as a zutan in the cells
regulating osmotic pressure in the
cells but its concentration
ranges from somewhere in micromolar
range to molar range wow so two tissues
like muscle for example and retina for
example are very high in
torine um and it is required for their
functioning because in torine deficiency
you have muscle wasting and retinal
degeneration in
humans so humans with the mutation of
this transporter slc6 A6 for example uh
have retinal degeneration and uh and
have a poor
eyesight uh in humans but there are also
animal models such as cats for example
cats cannot produce toine at all during
their life
cycle and because they cannot produce
their toine if their diet is deficient
in torine you have this precipitation of
growth defect and um blindness in cats
in fact that is how toine came into
Limelight oh interesting so all most of
toin was discovered in 1827 by two
scientists Tedman and galin but it
remained um like a ambiguous molecule
for a very long time almost 140 years
nobody cared for this molecule uh
because biochemistry and mor biology was
just evolving and in 1950s there was
this um increased demand from society to
provide pet foods and um when these Pet
Foods were provided um
in uh form of pallets to to the pets
there were many diseases that
precipitated like growth retardation
diabetes
obesity uh and so on the most striking
aspect of this episode was actually uh
development of blindness in the cats so
you can imagine these rich households
having these cats which are going blind
hitting walls and dropping was and
whatnot um and that uh was initial
impetus to really identify by what is in
the diet that is actually absent that is
causing the blindness in the cats and
from 1950s
to uh almost for 20 years uh scientists
trying to figure out what um is missing
in the diet and they identified in the
semal paper publishing SS um in' 70s
that retinal degeneration of blindness
in the cat is caused by a single
molecule deficiency in their diet and
that molecule is toine and since then
toine has mean cat diets have been
supplemented with toine including dogs
as well
now I see wow yeah that's super
interesting um and so as well with your
most recent study you noticed that um
when we age there seems to be a decline
in torine levels and obviously there are
going to be some tissues therefore that
might be more suable you've already
mentioned maybe the the eyes and the
resal tissue and muscle tissue and so
does that then suggest that the decline
is more likely due to be uh due to
dietary issues or do you think it's due
to the fact that the liver can't
generate as much as we age yeah so I I
would classify that as torine function
during aging and torine function decline
during aging we have noted that this is
due to three different uh events one is
the uh toine um uptake being compromised
from the
intestine second is uh toine not able to
act within the cells and there is a kind
of toine resistance in some
tissues and third is that inadequate
toine being produced by the tissues that
actually are having a limited capacity
to synthesize toine so all these three
events lead to functional toine
deficiency in um animal species and I I
would suspect that is going to be the
case in humans as well however uh I
should point out that we do not have a
good understanding of toin metabolism in
humans as of now especially during the
aging
process and so um in your paper once you
observed this so was that the initial
observation the de clim of age that
suggested that maybe we should try
supplementing it in the the mouse models
that you
used uh well this was the initial
impetus in fact uh initial impetus was
when we noted the uh B2 deficient
animals having less t having diseases of
Aging such as osteoporosis um anemia um
and cellular functions which are known
to be having known to be affected during
the aging process um but then we started
looking at okay does toine affect the
aging process because that was not known
uh when we were starting way back in 201
uh
12 and we measured toine levels in
different species and we noted that the
toin levels also tend to decline during
later part of our lives
uh especially when you compare with a
young age in fact if you compare with a
fetal tissues there is more dramatic
decline in a tissues so fetal tissues
compared to adult tissues have something
like five to 10 fold higher torine
levels W without us knowing what it is
doing in fetal
tissues so um and this to decline in
toing levels led us to then investigate
uh in Mouse uh we started and and to do
the intervention study where we did the
middle-aged animals which have low toine
levels we started feeding them toine
once daily uh after optimizing the dose
and frequency uh of this
intervention and that is what we noted
um is that toine intervention led to
increase in the lifespan of these
animals and not only lifespan it also
increased variety of Health parameters
in the animals in other words Health
span also was increased and The Morbid
period was suppressed at the end of our
lives uh in animals um and that was
initial study that led us to then
investigate uh across evolutionary
Spectrum including in worms in in East
in monkeys um and some experiments in
zebra fish um and finally in humans to
see what audian is doing dur engaging
process um as far as the health is
concerned H exactly and so in the paper
I believe that it wasn't sex specific it
was beneficial for both the male and
female mice but was there a difference
in terms of how effective it was that
you
noticed I think the in females responded
a bit better uh and there are these sex
differences that are also noted in other
interventions um sometimes females
respond better uh often actually females
respond better uh and males to a less
extent
and that has uh something to do with in
my view um
the reproductive cost of uh the Aging um
because uh reproduction and aging are
tightly linked um and species that
invest too much energy on the
reproduction uh have u perturbations in
the Aging
phenotypes and um so there are sex
differences in and aging interventions
that also depend on what are the
molecules being produced in in females
versus males and something to do with
these um ovian cyclicity uh that gets
compromised at later part of our Lives
um and in most species as
well I see and so when he looks at the
different uh benefits to their health in
terms of things like bone density on the
torine supplementation but that uh so
what would like the most shocking or
most interesting findings that you you
found um to me the most um interesting
aspect of these um entire thing was that
these animals were less
obese um although their body weight was
not dramatically reduced in t
supplemented animals uh their fat
deposition uh in abdomen and other
tissues was dramatically reduced and and
these animals had toine supplemented
animals had a dramatic increase in
energy
expenditure so you can imagine that now
these animals are the same except they
are having toine
supplementation and they have this
enormous burst of energy expenditure for
which I don't know what is the reason
behind it I would like to know uh one
day hopefully um because their diet the
the food intake was not dramatically
tried and they were depositing less fat
because they were burning more fat
H and that I think is very interesting
phenotype I would really want to know
because if we can figure it out we have
a means to for a major human
population which doesn't want to
exercise uh to reduce
obesity yeah no that's super interesting
CU I mean when I initially said it I
then may me think that maybe t then uh
when you increase the supplement uh the
amount being supplemented uh is
something to give the B and the
emulsification of fat but then in many
ways that would in theory increase fat
absorption I mean I'm not entirely sure
on how all sort of works but um instead
you're seeing increased energy
expenditure which then opposites to
maybe better mitochondrial functioning
or something linking with the
translation I'm not sure speculating
here um no that's definitely interesting
um but as well maybe things like uh the
uncoupling proteins because I know that
like um with the mitochondria and the
electron transport chain if you have
like the heat production so the
uncoupling protein um so Brown fat is
I'm trying to get to maybe that might be
a link I don't know um I guess yeah
there is increase in the ucb1 expression
in toine supplemented animals um and
ucp1 you pointed out clearly uh that has
an important role to play in uh
mitochondrial
respiration uh and there is a increase
abundance of ucp1 in toing supplemented
animals especially in the brown fat that
we noted um and that could be one way it
is actually involved in heat production
in the body um and perhaps one way these
animals have more energy expenditure ah
interesting okay um I on the
point that was kind of cool um so as
well in the study you also so also
you're supplementing the mice and um I
don't know how necessarily that would
translate to body like per kilogram to
humans because obviously humans we can
get it from things like energy drinks
obiously meat products um but what sort
of levels are people normally getting
from diets in terms of torine on a
day-to-day basis and how would that
compare to what you uh gave the mice in
the study so the um dietary intake um is
less because uh the highest amount of
Trine from the diet it is present in
Shell fishes which is approximate imely
1 mgram per gram of shellfish so even if
we eat um let us say 500 gr of shellfish
we get 500 milligrams of torine and that
is not the case Okay um now coming back
to what is the um human equalent doses
uh that we used in different species so
different species uh for example in mice
we use 500 milligram per kg body weight
or 1000 milligram per kg body weight the
monkeys it the do trans relateded to
approximately 250 migr per kg body
weight and if we now look at the human
equivalent doses there's a formula that
converts um Mouse doses to Monkey doses
to human doses uh which takes into
account surface area km values and Etc
uh human doses would be uh around three
or six gram per day of toine for a 80 kg
human being MH okay I see and so um the
paper that you sh the research that you
showed in the publication was that uh
based on like dietary intake I think
there was like an association with the
amount of toine present um actually I
can't quite remember what was in your
paper that's IAD at the very end of your
paper you showed some human data um what
was the finding from that part so um all
these species in uh investigations from
worms mice zebra fish monkeys uh led us
to think think um that toine deficiency
is a driver of Aging in these species
and the next question we address
actually was what happens in
humans and so we had access to these uh
12,000 uh subjects um longitudinal
Health Data uh which was available from
epig hisy and uh we then performed a
clinical uh correlation or clinical
Factor correlation with toine and its
metabolite levels in their blood and
what we identified is that if uh these
aged humans which are like 60y old
humans they had higher toine levels they
had a lower obesity lower BMI lower
waste to hip ratio less prevalence of
type two diabetes less
hypertension uh better glycemic index uh
less liver damage less inflammation
markers in the bloodstream and overall
it appears that toine abundance um
Associates uh with uh health status in
humans and lowor in abundance is
Associates with poor health in humans
conversely in humans we also
investigated uh what will happen to toin
metabolism in a healthy
State and what could be a healthy state
of a human being then exercise so we put
these sedentary individuals uh marathon
runners um bodybuilders and sprinters
through about of exercise um and this
bout of exercise in these individuals
led to increased abundance of torine and
its
metabolites irrespective of the kind of
individual we put them through exercise
regimen and that also tells you that
okay low toine abundance in aged humans
is associated with poor health and all a
healthy state of a human being is
associated with a better or more T in
abundance in their bloodstream and
perhaps uh some of the health benefits
of exercise are mediated by toine
abundance in the blood
stream and so given these findings um am
I right in thinking that you're now
hoping to set up human clinical trials
to test the efficacy of supplementing
with
torine you're absolutely right we are
putting together uh a multinational
trial where we are trying to figure out
no let me go back so we still do not
know how toin metabolism is going to to
change from one ethnicity and one
population to the other MH we only have
tested in one population the changes in
Torin and clinical variables right and
one could imagine toine being U coming
from a diet based
um or coming from a diet uh will have a
very strong changes when you look at a
uh population that remained uh omnivore
or that remained uh that became uh due
to development of Agriculture more grain
based
Hees so this um evolution of dietary
genetic interaction is still need to be
investigated especially when it comes to
toin um because if you look at the human
history the modern human history is 20
200,000 years right and you can see that
in the most of it this 200,000 years we
have been hunter gatherers in the
wild only in the last um let us say um
last well I would say uh 1200 years or
so we have now become
increasingly
um domesticated or we can call it we
have imposed self domesticated on
ourselves now not only we impose self
domestication on our C we also
domesticated
species yeah and if we have to learn
from this entire episode one thing we
can learn is that we when we introduce
these diets specific diets to these pets
they developed different diseases cats
and dogs and therefore we need to First
understand what is the requirement
depending on the genetic makeup of
individual which have migrated Out of
Africa a long time ago towards uh
Northern uh hemisphere or Southern
Hemisphere uh and developed different
dietary patterns perhaps genetics and
nutrition has um co-evolved together and
shaped this Evolution process um and we
are still trying to understand that what
is the different um or what is the
reference range of torine in different
population and also to do in humans um a
intervention study which we hope to uh
start uh hopefully uh by mid to late
next year uh where we are going to
investigate the whether toine
intervention delays the pace of Aging in
humans uh across different
populations nice um as as and so what
are sort of the market that you're Hing
to look at obviously a lot of U markets
are doing things like d inflation butly
in this case there's a lot of like uh
the looking at the bones density there's
a lot of other things that you might
want to consider in this case as I feel
like um things like zapia or blindness
as well like very interesting uh things
that seem to be uniquely tied to torine
supplementation as well so we we we want
to look at the health span of the human
being uh 6 months to one year after
toine
supplementation as well as we want to
look at different Hallmarks of Aging in
their blood stream such as for example
imuno
um looking at methylation clocks looking
at how their organs are aging uh in
different um through different analysis
of different markers in the bloodstream
uh and try to then uh put together uh an
analysis that can tell us whether toine
supplementation delays the pace of
biological aging and T is not the only
molecule that is going into T to
intervention trials now meaning there
are are increased interest in rapamycin
uh
metformin um and these are lead Runners
molecules which are going to go to
intervention trial um hopefully soon uh
and we will have probably in next 3 to
four years uh this uh anti-aging basket
full of these molecules which probably
will guide uh Precision medicine um in
next 5 to 10 years I would
suspect yeah no it's super exciting
times at the moment um i' say we've
one other thing that obviously uh happen
to ages we have defined in our immune
system is much known about the link
between torine and immune
function well a lot was known before we
started even in fact toine um has been
shown to be important for quenching
these oxidative species that are
generated during this oxidative burst
required for immune Cell
Activation and uh if
you look at PubMed you'll find molecules
like an chlorine or tooch chloramine
that actually are formed in immune cells
by combining hypochlorite a reactive
oxin species generated in immune cells
which has the potential to damage uh the
immune cell themselves but then toine
comes in picture it binds hypochloride
and makes tooch
chloramine so toine is very important
for immune cell function um and it has
been classically '90s there were a lot
of studies which looked at tooc
chloramine as a molecule as a potent
antioxidant um in the antioxidant
process especially when it comes to the
oxidative burst of immune
cells interesting and so uh is most of
your lab at the moment focused on torine
or are there any other interests that
you're investigating at the
moment so we are um looking at uh
different nutrient uh molecules how
dietary composition how these uh
nutrients shape up the genetic makeup of
individuals and how genetics informs the
nutrient uh intake at the same time uh
to to Really identify as I said in the
beginning itself the domestication of a
species including humans uh were
beneficial for many things for example
we were able to uh cure many diseases
which were like uh infectious diseases
and so on but then it also precipitated
many other diseases which um were caused
by this nutrient uh genetic imbalance so
if we can identify these nutrient
factors or the molecules which are
required for our uh in our diets which
affect the health perhaps we have one
way or simpler ways to really benefit
Health without going to uh
pharmacological drugs even um and that
is one uh major interest that I have uh
and we continue to explore other
molecules uh which can part participate
in regulating solell Health nice so
what's been really nice about talking
with you today is I love the way that
everything you've done throughout your
career so far has kind of like been a
step onwards from what we've done before
like that's been a logical connection so
as a student myself and I know some
students also watch I just uh curious to
know if you have any sort of advice for
being a scientist or any sort of uh
lessons that you've learned throughout
your career so far uh well I think uh
one of the most important lesson uh I
have learned is that you need to follow
your passion there are going to be a lot
of ups and downs in your um career
trajectory uh well mostly Downs uh but
one has to keep uh your Your Enthusiasm
alive do uh bit by bit uh slowly
continue to build your uh knowledge
expertise and uh address important
question and as long as you are
passionate about um addressing a
question you will find an answer may not
be the perfect answer uh because biology
is a fluid process which keeps on
evolving and our knowledge um keeps on
changing as we keep accumulating new
information through new technologies but
at the end it is just follow your
passion and you'll find your way exactly
and I also was curious about um you have
an extensive knowledge about the history
of the the research that you're doing as
well in terms of like the earlier papers
that were published and I was curious to
know I mean how do you go about like
keeping up with literature or reading
older literature is it mainly based on
papers or do you read much much uh books
or uh do yeah do you have any book
recommendations uh for my
viewers I actually was um a bookworm by
back in my PhD so I used read lot of
these um old journals I think that is no
longer um a
um exciting thing for um current
generation including myself now at the
moment um because we tend to uh believe
in lot of uh knowledge that we gain by
just Googling information and uh Google
can be a very uh informative venue to
look information but at the same time
you need to be knowledgeable enough to
fish out right information from the
wrong
information because everybody seems to
have an opinion today for anything that
comes um in any field for example people
can have opinions and science does not
run by opinions it runs by uh
experimental data and facts generated by
hard work uh which people put through
you know you can imagine uh people
working day in and day out trying to
figure out some problems but having an
opinion is easy to have but at the same
time we need to be considerate of um the
literat that is present uh go back to
the original studies that actually
established those founding principles
and that also elucidates how these
technologies have evolved and what can
we do better going forward as far as
Technologies are
concerned no I like that I think we
share the same mindset soly I'm blessed
somewhat with being in Cambridge UK at
the moment which has like so many nice
uh old book stores so I have I've
accumulated a few old old books myself
and I think well the other reason why I
I say it's a wise idea is that but you
mentioned we Google things nowadays but
obviously sometimes a lot of old books
there's not PDF versions so there's not
an easy way of that information being
put on online so you can't find it
unless you actually go to that the the
source and actually read it and yeah
with current experimental improvements
maybe there are things that were
suggested that we can now actually test
and do more rigorously so um I'm in
agree with that mindset um well thank
you I think I think we have the same
point
uh excellent so um no it's been great
speaking with you today uh and I'm
really looking forward to hearing more
about the the trial with torine um as
everything sort of happens hopefully
next year and um it's been fascinating
to hear about your career project uh
trajectory and um yeah I hope I wish you
just the best of success of everything
going
forward thank you very much elor it was
a pleasure being on your show and um
well is always a learning process and I
am delighted uh hopefully people will uh
see this experience and uh Take It
Forward uh
science thank
you